Deku loses his mind as he has to give up
one for all to another user deku's
biggest weakness against shigaraki is
threatening to destroy the heroes and
the only solution could be a new 10th
user of one for all and if that's not
crazy enough star and stripe is back
from the dead and so is her epic work
new order the twist at the end was
shocking so let's get into it in the
previous chapter we saw that shigaraki
was already using danger sense The Quirk
he stole from Deku against Deku in
battle this made it much easier for
shigaraki to dodge and anticipate deku's
attacks and to make things worse deku's
gear shift is apparently wearing off
although to be honest it's been wearing
off for like 10 chapters or something on
the bright side when shigaraki stole
danger sense he did not steal all the
power that all for one had accumulated
within itself over the course of nine
Generations so even though Deku can't
use danger sense anymore at least he
isn't actually physically weaker than he
used to be the other key point that the
previous chapter established is that
awakened shigaraki is a far more
dangerous villain than even all for one
himself shigaraki literally just wants
to destroy all of Japan he doesn't want
to rule Japan he doesn't want to lead an
underworld Empire he just wants to
literally annihilate the entire country
starting with the iconic volcanic
Mountain Mount Fuji the chapter ended
with shigaraki initiating Decay on the
ground and moving it towards Mount Fuji
in order to trigger a massive volcanic
eruption what happens next is absolutely
crazy but first a quick word from our
sponsor okay picture this what if a
legendary RPG game has sponsored this
video and you get to hear all about its
huge collection of over 700 unique
Champions a super awesome RPG battle
system amazing graphics and an intense
combination of PVE and PVP content well
lucky for you this video is sponsored by
that game so let me tell you more about
rage Shadow Legends right now the worlds
of Rage Shadow Legends and Monster
Hunter are colliding in an awesome but
limited time crossover from January 9th
2024 to March 5th players will be able
to collect five monster Hunter themed
Legendary Champions based on iconic
monsters from capcom's action RPG
franchise these five Champions are based
on iconic Monster Hunter monsters
including Rathalos zogre Ruiner Nur
Gigante alatreon and the very badass
looking Fatalis everyone will be able to
get Rathalos blad Master legendary
champion for free simply by logging into
raid for 7 days between now and February
27th while the other four will be
available through in-game events there
will also be themed community events and
other special event so this is
definitely one crossover you don't want
to miss I've personally been playing
raid for years now and I love the unique
Champions the team building and attack
Graphics especially ones that attack all
the enemies at the same time I strongly
recommend it so don't delay and download
raid Now using my link in the
description to start working towards
getting your free Rathalos blade master
champion and join the hunt today and
even though the holiday season's over
the excitement in rage hat Legend
Continues the Cur city is one of Ray's
biggest features since the Doom Tower
with 100 stages to complete and even
ones where where you need to take down
two raid bosses at the same time by
working your way through it you can even
get your hands on a mythical champion
and there's still time to use promo code
raid xmus before the end of January to
score exclusive in-game prizes so what
are you waiting for click the link in
the description or scan the QR code now
and new players will even get this
starter pack with an epic Champion Drake
for absolutely free the latest chapter
picks up as Deku is fighting to stop
shigaraki's Decay from spreading to
Mount Fuji deu is using maximum fudin
plus the wind pressure technique plus
Delaware smash to essentially blow the
ground away from shigaraki's Decay which
stops it from spreading further shikaki
acknowledges that this is a very clever
tactic but it's just a temporary delay
all shigaraki has to do is touch the
ground over and over again and
eventually Deku will not be able to stop
it and the growth of the Decay will
continue but as shigaraki tries to
attack the ground deu uses smoke screen
combined with gear shifts low gear to
spread a bunch of smoke around the
battlefield and make it last longer than
usual then as shigaraki enters the smoke
cloud Deku uses a bunch of his black
whip tentacles to confuse and overwhelm
shigaraki's danger sense and this allows
deu to sneak up on shigaraki and deliver
a devastating blow that takes
shigaraki's entire right arm off now of
course shigaraki has super regeneration
but the hit looked cool at least deu is
using the intimate knowledge he has
about danger sense to exploit its
vulnerabilities including the fact that
it can sometimes be very unreliable that
is very clever and interesting but
danger sense is not the only trick
shigaraki has up his sleeve shigaraki
still has the Quirk surge a quirk that
all for one had stolen from ragd doll
all those chapters ago and this Quirk
allows him to determine the location and
weaknesses of up to 100 people at a time
including of course deu shigaraki uses
search to find Deku in Smoke and attack
him with rivet stab as shigaraki's
attack seems to land some blows on Deku
the hero looks absolutely exhausted he
looks like he is about to pass out and
banjo points out that gear shift is
ending and so Deku is about to suffer
the consequences of The Recoil even
shigaraki is noticing that Deku seems to
be at the end of his rope he had been
reinforcing his tendons and muscles from
the inside he was trying everything he
can to keep fighting but even though the
attacks he was able to deliver were
powerful it is clear that Deku can't
keep this up for long shigaraki is
confident that Deku is about to fall
before his might there is just no way
thatu can Prevail after already
exhausting so much of his reserves but
the stubborn Maniac that is deu
absolutely refuses to give up and
craziest of all he refuses to give up on
that crying boy referring to little
tenos shimura the boy who eventually
turned into the villain tomura shigaraki
as the entire world watches the battle
on their TVs shigaraki tries to show
Deku that it's hopeless little tenko
inside shigaraki is no longer the same
boy that he once was according to
shigaraki that little boy stopped crying
a long time ago he changed the lens
through which he saw the world and he
willingly turned into tomura shigaraki
little tenko is no longer a victim he is
no longer crying and suffering he is now
none other than tomura shigaraki as he
says this shigaraki shows us some sort
of dark sphere made of Urban Decay that
is supposed to portray his inner State
of Mind at this moment it looks like
something out of inception however
knowing Hoshi someday we will get to see
that sphere burst apart and de on the
inside we will find little tenko shimura
once again like it or hate it you know
he's going to go there Deku still
refuses to accept what the villain is
saying and he vows that he still wants
to save that boy at this point tenko's
own Grandma Nana shimura feels like she
has to intervene so her vestage appears
before dein tells him to give up because
some people simply can't be saved it's
time to finish shigaraki right now with
a single powerful attack before he can
do even more more devastating damage to
Japan and the rest of the world but even
though Nana herself is telling Deku to
do this he says no because it is clear
that the prospect of losing her grandson
is hurting her deeply even as she says
all these things Deku vows to fight for
everyone who had their pain swept under
the rug by the failings of the old hero
society and that includes tenos shimura
he vows to shred that rug with his own
hands at this point the second user says
that this is why he didn't want to
acknowledge Deku at first he saw the boy
as a peace-seeking fool who wanted to
save their mortal enemy shigaraki
instead of actually defeating him after
looking into deku's Memories the second
user now knows that Deku will not give
up on literally anyone he didn't give up
on bakugo after all the bullying that
bakugo put him through during their
childhood and he is not going to give up
on anyone else that is just the kind of
person Deku is for better or worse and
then in that moment something shocking
happens as they are looking into
shigaraki's all for one vestage world
the vestages of the second user and all
might see Star and strip's hand pointing
towards the center of the dark sphere
that shikaki had shown them earlier he
says we are betting on you ninth you
have to let go of one for all wait what
what does this mean is the second's
vestage saying that deu has to transfer
one for all to a tenth user someone who
will actually be willing to kill
shigaraki in order to save the rest of
the world or is the vestage saying that
deu has to allow shigaraki to steal one
for all from him because then the
vestages within one for all will be able
to work together with star and stripe
inside of shigaraki for one vestage
world in order to potentially awaken the
little ten Kimura within him and bring
the villain down from the inside why did
we see the hand of star and stripe who
is supposed to be dead is part of her
still inside shigaraki's all for one
vestage world and waiting to bring him
down with the help of the one forall
vestages let me know down below the next
chapter will hopefully bring us a lot
more information about what that ending
means but in my personal opinion this
means that the one forall vestages will
try to destroy shigaraki from the inside
they will let shigaraki try to steal one
for all and when he does that the
vestages will meet up with the vestage
of star and stripe within shigaraki's
All For One vestage World and then they
will BR an internal Rebellion against
him they will attempt to break apart
that dark sphere and pull little tenko
out from within they will all try to
save tenko together while defeating the
villain known as tomura shigaraki at the
same time but if this outcome requires
Deku to give up one for all so that
shigaraki can steal it then does that
mean that the climax of the final battle
will be an internal struggle between the
vestages I think there has to be an epic
internal battle between the vestages and
an epic external battle between deu and
shigaraki in the real world I definitely
want to see star and stripee a new order
in action once again but at the end of
the day there will have to be some sort
of external fight that is going on in
the physical world like there's no way
deu is going to sit out the final battle
while the vestiges fight for him so it
will have to be some sort of mixed
internal and external struggle at least
that's my opinion now how is deu going
to fight if he has to give up one for
all I don't know but if you have some
thoughts let me know down in the
comments willu end up quirkless again
will he give up like a of one for all
but keep another part will someone else
step in to fight shigaraki in the
physical world for deu let me know what
you think down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more M content in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and if you want
to help this channel reach 2 million
subscribers on YouTube please do me a
big favor and subscribe right now we are
less than 5K away thanks again to raid
Shadow Legends for sponsoring this video
check them out right now Link in the
description